-Elle aime
manier les chiffres,
éplucher les projets
de lois de finances,
mais la technicienne
est devenue plus politique
au point de s'imposer
comme une figure incontournable
de la droite.
Générique
...
Bonjour,
Véronique Louwagie.
-Bonjour.
-Vous siégez à l'Assemblée
depuis 2012 sous les couleurs
des Républicains.
Il a fallu attendre
votre 3e mandant
pour que Le Figaro
vous consacre
un article titré :
"Véronique Louwagie,
"révélation de la droite
à l'Assemblée."
C'est pas un peu vexant,
après plus de 10 ans,
qu'on vous qualifie de révélation ?
-Pas du tout.
On peut exister sans faire
la une des médias.
Effectivement, je suis
passionnée des chiffres.
C'est mon métier, expert-comptable.
J'aime aller au bout des choses,
et on prend du temps
à comprendre les mécaniques
des finances publiques,
d'un projet de loi de finances,
d'un budget de l'Etat,
et je les comprends.
-De l'Assemblée nationale aussi ?
-Oui, parce que j'ai voulu,
en 2012, faire partie
de la Commission des finances,
aussitôt quand je suis arrivée ici,
et je n'ai pas pu immédiatement
parce qu'en 2012,
parmi les députés
de la droite,
il y avait un grand nombre
d'anciens ministres,
et l'accès à la Commission
des finances leur a été réservé.
Donc j'ai dû attendre.
-En gros, les barons de la droite
trustaient les places,
occupaient la première ligne ?
-Oui.
C'était ça, parce qu'il y avait,
je dirais, une certaine envie,
en tout cas une certaine fierté
d'être à la Commission des finances,
un certain prestige,
et j'ai dû attendre 2014,
où là, François Baroin,
qui faisait partie
de la Commission des finances,
est parti au Sénat,
et il y a eu une place.
Comme je suivais ça
comme le lait sur le feu,
j'ai pu y accéder.
-Ce terme de "révélation"
du Figaro peut surprendre
et en même temps,
dans cette assemblée
sans majorité absolue, vous avez
pris une dimension nouvelle,
sur la remise
sur les prix du carburant
ou sur la réforme des retraites.
C'est vous, avez Olivier Marleix,
qui êtes allés négocier à Matignon,
avec Elisabeth Borne,
ou à Bercy,
avec Bruno Le Maire.
Ce sont des nouvelles
responsabilités
qui vous ont plu ?
-Oui, effectivement,
sur les deux mandats précédents,
la situation était différente.
Nous nous retrouvons avec un paysage
politique particulier
à l'Assemblée, et le gouvernement
essaie de discuter
avec un certain nombre de groupes,
dont Les Républicains,
et Olivier Marleix
m'a associée pour ce qui concernait
les finances et m'a laissée
un peu maître pour discuter
sur le premier
projet de loi de finances
rectificatif,
et je me suis retrouvée à discuter
avec la Première ministre
et ensuite avec Bruno Le Maire
lors du débat,
lors de l'examen de ces textes,
et c'était inédit, dans la forme,
car nous ne connaissions pas,
et puis me retrouver ici,
je dirais que c'était
un peu particulier.
-Vous avez pris du plaisir
à vous retrouver
au coeur du pouvoir ?
-Dire que j'ai trouvé du plaisir
à être en première ligne,
non, mais j'ai trouvé
de la satisfaction
à pouvoir être active,
finalement,
et à pouvoir avoir les mains
dans le cambouis,
être proche pour discuter,
être le relais
de mon groupe,
et j'ai essayé
de le faire au mieux.
Et je me souviens qu'un jour,
le ministre m'a demandé
de le retrouver à l'Assemblée
nationale en m'indiquant :
"Nous nous retrouvons
au bureau des ministres."
-Un bureau des ministres ?
-J'ignorais, après 10 ans
de présence ici,
qu'il y avait un bureau
des ministres.
Ca n'était pas habituel.
-Vous l'avez trouvé ?
-Oui,
j'ai demandé à Olivier Marleix
où était ce bureau,
et c'est lui qui me l'a indiqué.
Finalement, il n'y avait
que les députés qui étaient là,
quand ils appartenaient
à la majorité,
donc pas beaucoup à droite,
qui connaissaient son existence,
des personnes plus proches,
je dirais,
de la manne politique
et de l'organisation.
-Sur les retraites, vous avez trouvé
un compromis avec le gouvernement,
mais une partie des députés LR
a refusé de voter
cette réforme,
alors que vous étiez engagée
auprès d'Elisabeth Borne
au nom du groupe LR.
Vous l'avez vécu
comme un échec personnel ?
-Non, je crois que ça n'est pas
un échec personnel.
Nous avons une nouvelle méthode
à construire au niveau
de l'Assemblée nationale,
et nous apprenons.
Je crois que le gouvernement
aussi apprend,
et nous, les groupes
de l'opposition, nous apprenons.
Moi, je veux construire.
Nous avons cinq ans,
le pays a besoin de nous.
Il faut que nous puissions avancer.
Donc je ne renonce aucunement
à mes convictions,
parce que c'est important,
je les porte de manière forte,
mais quand quelque chose est bien,
il faut pouvoir avancer.
Il faut que nous tirions
des enseignements de nos erreurs,
de nos échecs, parce que...
-Sur ce sujet,
ça a pas fonctionné ?
-Non.
Nous en sortons affaiblis.
Donc il faut rebondir.
Il faut tirer des forces
de ses échecs.
C'est ce que nous faisons
avec Olivier Marleix et Eric Ciotti.
-Vous êtes l'une des députés
les plus assidus dans l'hémicycle.
J'ai lu qu'à plusieurs reprises,
vous avez siégée seule
sur les bancs de la droite,
et vos adversaires
ont rebaptisé votre groupe LR
du nom de vos initiales, VL,
pour Véronique Louwagie.
C'est vrai, ça ?
-Oui, c'est vrai.
L'examen d'un projet
de loi de finances
dure assez longtemps.
-On vous voit :
vous êtes toute seule.
-Oui.
Vous avez des séances
qui commencent
le lundi à 16h et qui se terminent
quelques fois le samedi
ou le dimanche.
Effectivement, je me suis retrouvée
quelques fois seule,
et donc voilà,
un petit peu
par sourire, par rire,
les députés des autres groupes
m'ont appelée "le groupe VL".
-Qu'est-ce qui
vous fait tenir dans des séances
de nuit, parfois jusqu'à 1h,
à défendre des amendements
de vos collègues du groupe LR,
qui sont pour la plupart rejetés ?
-Je pense que j'ai un peu
le sens de la perfection,
en tout cas de l'engagement.
Là, je me suis engagée
au nom du groupe les députés
Les Républicains
sur cette question du projet
de loi de finances,
et donc je vais jusqu'au bout,
en tout cas, j'y prends...
Je suis revenue plusieurs fois
les dimanches,
pour être l'orateur
du groupe Les Républicains
au moment des discussion
sur les motions de censure,
en tout cas,
je suis très attachée à ça.
J'ai une valeur importante
sur la notion d'engagement.
-Vous faites partie du club
des spécialistes
des finances publiques.
Vous avez été élue vice-présidente
de la Commission.
Les finances publiques,
ça fait pas rêver les députés.
C'est souvent jugé technique,
un peu rébarbatif.
C'est votre passé
d'expert-comptable,
qui vous a attirée vers ça ?
-Vous savez,
quand on est expert-comptable,
on aime quand même les chiffres,
sinon, ce serait une catastrophe.
Elle rit.
Voilà, donc on a une attirance.
J'ai beaucoup appris aussi
avec Gilles Carrez à partir de 2014.
-Ancien président de la Commission
des finances.
-Oui, un spécialiste
des finances publiques.
Et les finances publiques,
c'est la déclinaison
de toutes les politiques publiques,
qui parlent au quotidien
aux Français,
sur la question de la santé,
de l'éducation, du logement.
Je pense qu'au travers
les chiffres, derrière, je dirais
qu'il y a des orientations,
des prismes qui concernent
tous les Français,
et je veux améliorer
un certain nombre de points
qui concernent la vie
des Français.
C'est mon objectif.
D'où cette importance
des comptes publics.
-Votre premier engagement
remonte à 1983.
Vous aviez 22 ans.
Vous avez été élue
conseillère municipale
d'un petit village dans l'Eure,
où vous habitiez.
On vous voit d'ailleurs
en photo, là,
dans une course de sacs.
C'est la jeune conseillère
municipale.
Mais plus rien
jusqu'aux années 2000, pourquoi ?
-Alors j'ai été effectivement
conseillère municipale
sur un mandat qui a duré six ans,
et ensuite, juste avant
de finir ce mandat,
j'ai eu deux enfants,
j'en attendais un troisième,
j'ai eu trois enfants en trois ans,
et je me suis engagée aussi
dans une activité d'expert-comptable
où j'ai créé mon cabinet.
J'avais beaucoup d'engagements
familiaux et professionnels,
et ayant déménagé,
je n'avais plus aucun attrait
dans cette commune
où j'avais été élue.
Donc je me suis retrouvée
à m'occuper de mes enfants
et de mon cabinet
d'expertise comptable,
où j'ai passé beaucoup de temps,
trouvé beaucoup de plaisir
et me suis beaucoup engagée.
-La politique est revenue
dans votre vie
et tout s'est accéléré
à partir de 2010.
En trois ans,
vous avez été
conseillère régionale,
départementale
puis députée en 2012.
Pour les législatives,
vous y êtes allée contre l'avis
de votre famille.
Ils voulaient pas ?
-On a fait un petit
conseil de famille,
avec mon époux
et mes trois enfants,
et tous les quatre m'ont dit :
"Il ne faut pas que tu y ailles."
Donc je les ai laissés parler.
Ca a duré une heure,
et j'ai dit : "J'irai."
-Donc vous avez été élue.
Vous en êtes à votre 3e mandat.
Vous dites que le plus dur,
c'est pas la première élection,
c'est la deuxième.
-Oui.
A la première élection,
vous n'êtes pas élu,
je dirais, sur un bilan.
Vous bénéficiez,
je dirais,
de la méconnaissance
de votre personne.
Donc on peut faire confiance.
La deuxième, vous êtes élu
sur un bilan, sur un passé,
avec quelques fois
des prises de position
qui ne correspondent pas forcément
aux attentes des citoyens.
Je dirais que c'est
beaucoup plus difficile
parce que vous n'avez plus
le bénéfice du doute.
Je le dis à tous mes collègues.
La deuxième élection,
c'est la plus difficile.
-Localement, vous avez mis en place
un dispositif original
de démocratie participative.
Vous appelez ça les conseils
de circonscription.
Ca fonctionne comment ?
-Effectivement,
j'ai voulu faire en sorte
que ce fossé entre les citoyens
et le député, ou les élus
d'une manière générale,
qu'il soit moins important.
Donc j'ai créé un groupe
avec 70 personnes.
J'ai fait des appels à candidatures,
des personnes ont répondu.
Nous avons ensuite fait
une sélection
en fonction notamment des âges,
pour avoir autant de femmes
que d'hommes, de répartition aussi
sur la circonscription,
de profils, et ces personnes
se réunissent régulièrement,
en conseil de circonscription,
avec une déclinaison
en commissions,
économie, santé...
-Et vous les faites travailler
sur des sujets comme ça ?
-Nous avons travaillé
sur la fin de vie.
-Et ils votent ?
-Pas toujours, mais sur le dernier
conseil, je les ai fait voter.
-Ces votes, vous en faites quoi ?
Ca vous engage ?
-Ca ne m'engage pas,
parce que je suis libre
de mes convictions,
mais en revanche, ça m'alimente,
et c'est très important
que nous ayons un point
de discernement du terrain,
des remontées
du terrain.
Je crois
que c'est fort.
-Passons au quizz.
Vous allez devoir compléter
les phrases que je vais proposer.
-D'accord.
-C'est parti.
"A ceux qui disent que je pourrais
rallier Emmanuel Macron..."
-Pas possible.
-Votre nom circule, parfois.
-Oui, mais laissez
les noms circuler.
-"La meilleure blague
"entre experts-comptables..."
-Alors on est assez sérieux,
on est basés un peu sur le réel,
puisqu'on constate
la réalité à travers des bilans
et des comptes de résultats.
On se dit :
"A quoi servent les économistes ?"
Notre blague, c'est :
"Heureusement qu'ils sont là
"pour rire d'eux."
-Ils partent dans des...
-Oui,
et nous, les comptables,
nous ne sommes pas forcément
des gens très drôles,
en général.
-"Quand je ne serais
plus députée..."
-Je pourrai pouponner
mes petits-enfants.
J'en ai 10.
-C'est compliqué,
avec votre
engagement.
-Oui, mais je disais
à mes collègues députés :
"Faites comme moi.
"Ayez 10 petits-enfants,
il y aura plus de problèmes
"de réforme des retraites."
-Voilà.
Merci beaucoup, Véronique Louwagie,
d'être venue.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...